(soft music)
- I know it feels really bad right now.
- I know I feel scared.
And I feel alone.
- Whatever you feel right now,
the emotions, they're valid.
- The only thing I can do is
stand here and tell you that
you're not alone.
- All over the world, people
that you didn't even know
are rooting for you.
Are rooting for you, starting with me.
- What makes you unique is
what makes you beautiful.
It's what makes you lovable.
It's what makes you incredible.
- It's going to be really
easy right now to feel
defeated and exhausted.
- We are standing by you in
solidarity throughout this.
- Now is the time where
it's really important
for you to stand your ground and say,
"This is who I am."
- For every person that you run into
who maybe believes that it's their right
to treat you differently,
you're going to find so many other people
who will treat you with
kindness and respect.
- And you belong here.
- And you can definitely
make a difference.
- You have an inner strength
you don't even know is there.
But I know it's there.
- It just takes so much
work and so much patience.
- You don't have to do this alone.
- We are so with you.
- We're with you.
- And if America is
ever going to be great,
you're going to be the reason.
- You are not powerless in this.
You have the action to make change.
- Read, engage, be veracious.
Volunteer with your local groups.
- Nothing is accomplished by giving up.
- We might take one step back,
but we just have to take
two steps forward again.
- This is not where we stop fighting,
or loving, or hugging.
- Things will get better,
because we are the ones
that are going to make
sure that that happens.
- The time is now.
We don't need to wait another second.
- Don't lie down and don't accept things
that are not acceptable.
- We will not fall prey to hate.
- Good definitely still exists.
- Puppies.
(laughs)
- Kittens, have you seen a kitten lately?
- And I love you.
We love you.
- We love you.
- When people get set
back, that's when they
come back the strongest.
- And we need to stand for the things,
and for the people that we believe in.
(soft music)